hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to time or now if you
remember NOx time or it was a game that
I played a while ago that a lot of
really good scares and also it spawned
an animation made by cranbersher oh it's
an endless hallway is it oh hey I see
you over there you want to fight bro are
you ready for the Smackdown can I help
you oh god damn it don't try to do that
with me
oh hey is this tonight can I drop down
this giant hole can I go to the bloody
toilet wait a minute that's different
I lost were okay what okay hi how's it
going hey friends been a while since I
saw you all right cool we're all having
fun here oh so that's how you gonna play
this game a game baby I'm home come out
and scare me oh boy yay nothing hello
oh no oh okay
is that a watermelon or a face I'm not
sure but it's bloody so it's a bleeding
laughs [ __ ] all right cool great I'm
just gonna be on my way
hearts pounding out of my chest but
that's okay I'm just gonna suck you
wonder what's gonna happen now Oh a
demon's gonna pop out and go boo boo are
you gonna do it again
you did it again you son of a [ __ ] what
the hell where am I oh no oh.look dead
body are you made of watermelons
when I knew I'm gonna be stuck here
forever
where's Wilson ah not sure what I walked
up on